[Musik]
dann haben sie vor gonzalez nicht mehr
gesehen
ungefähr zwei wochen hat sie mir nicht
gesagt wohin sie geht wissen sie nicht
ob sie verreisen wollen und sie wenn es
nichts gesagt
warum haben sie die polizei nicht früher
informiert
na ja da kann man zwei wochen weg sein
oder haben sie ihre handynummer alle sie
anrufen ja aber ich erreiche sie nicht
das sind meine eltern was machen denn
ihre eltern
mein vater ist anwalt und meine mutter
ingenieurin
glauben sie dass ihre tante in spanien
ist und ihre eltern besucht können sie
ihre eltern anrufen und fragen sie sich
ja nicht wird der kontakt ist nicht sehr
gut
wohin sparen den bohnen ihre eltern
meine eltern wohnen
was macht jahre in der schweiz
[Musik]